En astrophysique, on nous parle souvent
de la distance
à laquelle se trouvent les étoiles:
à tant de milliers d’années-lumière.
Pour les galaxies c’est encore pire,
ça chiffre en millions
voire en milliards d’années-lumière.
Mais comment on connait ces distances?
On n’a pas fait l’aller-retour sur place
pour mesurer.
Et a priori on n’a pas fait ça non plus
avec un double décimètre.
Eh bien pour mesurer la distance des objets
astrophysiques,
on se base sur toute une série de méthodes
qui forment ce qu’on appelle l’échelle
des distances cosmiques.
On utilise l’image d’une échelle
à laquelle on grimperait,
car ces méthodes dépendent
les unes des autres.
Chaque méthode doit être mise au point
et calibrée en utilisant la précédente.
Comme quand on s’appuie successivement
sur les différents barreaux d’une échelle
pour l’escalader.
Et c’est ça qu’on va voir aujourd’hui:
on va grimper ensemble à l’échelle des
distances cosmiques.
[jingle]
Pour attaquer notre voyage, on va commencer
avec l’objet astronomique
le plus simple et le plus proche qui
se trouve dans notre ciel: la Lune.
Comment on sait à quelle distance
elle se trouve?
Eh bien aujourd’hui on utilise
ce qu’on appelle la "télémétrie laser".
On tire un laser depuis la Terre,
et on mesure le temps
que met la lumière pour faire l’aller-retour.
Et ça fonctionne parce que plusieurs
missions lunaires ont déposé
sur place des réflecteurs qui permettent
de renvoyer vers nous
une partie de la lumière
qui arrive sur place.
On connait la vitesse de la lumière,
on sait très bien mesurer le temps
avec des horloges très précises.
On peut donc en déduire la distance
de la Terre à la Lune
avec une précision assez diabolique,
de l’ordre d’un centimètre.
Évidemment ça c’est pour une mesure
ponctuelle,
car la distance change en permanence.
Déjà, on sait que la Lune s’éloigne
de quelques centimètres par an.
Mais surtout comme son orbite n’est pas
un cercle parfait,
c’est une ellipse très légèrement aplatie,
eh bien la distance avec la Terre change
tout le temps le long de la trajectoire.
Mais aujourd’hui, on connait les paramètres
de l’ellipse
et donc l’orbite de la Lune avec
une précision excellente.
Et en moyenne sa distance à la Terre
est d’environ 385 000 km.
La télémétrie laser, c’est une méthode
de mesure très directe,
qui est donc celle qu’on utilise aujourd’hui.
Mais on n’a pas toujours fait comme ça!
Dès le IIe siècle avant J.C.,
l’astronome grec
Hipparque avait obtenu d’excellents résultats
avec une technique différente
: la méthode de la parallaxe.
Elle repose sur un principe géométrique
dont vous pouvez tous faire l’expérience.
Tenez un objet devant vous,
disons un crayon,
avec derrière un arrière-plan
suffisamment lointain.
Fermez un œil pour que ça marche mieux,
et regardez votre crayon en déplaçant
légèrement votre tête.
Si vous gardez le crayon au centre
de votre champ de vision,
vous aurez l’impression que c’est
l’arrière-plan qui bouge derrière.
Plus l’objet est proche de votre œil,
plus l’effet est important.
Et inversement, avec des objets lointains,
pour un même mouvement de votre tête,
le déplacement apparent de l’arrière-plan
sera moins prononcé.
C’est l’effet de parallaxe.
Et ça marche donc aussi avec la Lune
dans le ciel.
L’effet est très faible, et
pour s’en rendre compte
j’ai codé un petit truc en utilisant Unity,
qui est un moteur de jeu vidéo.
Ici on commence en vue "3e personne",
la caméra est fixe,
on voit la Lune au fond, et j’ai mis
derrière un fond de ciel fictif.
Et ici en rose mon petit personnage que
je vais déplacer de droite à gauche,
et qui garde les yeux rivés sur la Lune,
simple!
Passons maintenant en vue subjective, à la
première personne.
Maintenant, je vois ce que voit
mon personnage,
et je vous ai mis en haut à gauche
la vue de la caméra précédente.
Si maintenant je déplace mon personnage et
qu’il fixe la Lune,
vous voyez qu’on a l’impression que
c’est l’arrière-plan qui bouge.
Je peux aussi éloigner ou rapprocher la Lune,
et vous voyez que si je la mets plus loin,
pour un même déplacement de mon personnage,
l’effet de parallaxe sera plus faible.
Là j’ai énormément exagéré, mais l’effet
existe bien en pratique.
Quand on voit la Lune, il y a des étoiles
en arrière-plan qui sont très éloignées
et si on observe depuis différent endroits
sur Terre,
la position apparente de la Lune par rapport
aux étoiles ne sera pas la même.
Pour s’en rendre compte, il faut juste
prendre des positions
éloignées de plusieurs centaines
de kilomètres.
Pour vous donner une idée, j’ai utilisé
un logiciel de planétarium.
Je me suis mis à la pleine lune
de ce mois-ci,
et j’ai entré les coordonnées de Lille
et de Perpignan,
disons 1000km à vol d’oiseau.
Et voilà au-même instant ce qu’on verrait.
Vous voyez que la position apparente
des étoiles de l’arrière plan
est très légèrement différente
sur les deux images.
C’est à cause de l’effet de parallaxe.
Cette différence de position,
on va la mesurer comme un angle.
C’est la différence angulaire,
dans le ciel,
entre les positions des étoiles
de l’arrière-plan.
Avec mon exemple de Lille et Perpignan
c’est vraiment minime,
la différence est environ 1/6e de degré.
Mais une fois qu’on a cette valeur,
c’est simplement un peu de trigonométrie.
Nos deux positions et la lune forment
un triangle isocèle,
on connait l’angle et la distance de la base,
on peut en déduire la distance
de la Terre à la Lune.
C’est juste de la géométrie,
aucune hypothèse physique.
Petite précision de langage
sur la mesure des angles.
Des angles qui sont des fractions de degrés
c’est pas évident,
alors pour parler de très petits angles,
on va diviser le degré
en 60 parties qu’on appelle
des "minutes d’arc",
1/6e de degré, c’est donc un angle
de 10 minutes d’arc.
Et si besoin on divisera encore la minute
en secondes,
donc ici, 600 secondes d’arc.
Cette méthode de la parallaxe, c’est donc
supposément ce qu’aurait utilisé Hipparque
pour faire une estimation de la distance
de la Lune.
On n’a pas tout les détails, mais il se peut
qu’en guise d’arrière-plan,
il ait carrément utilisé le Soleil,
à l’occasion d’une éclipse.
Et il aurait trouvé environ 400 000 km,
ce qui est quand même incroyablement
bon pour l’époque,
puisque la vraie valeur c'est 385 000.
Bien tout ça, c’était juste pour la Lune,
passons à l’objet suivant,
le Soleil justement.
Avec lui la méthode de la parallaxe ça va
être compliqué
parce que déjà il est beaucoup plus loin
que la Lune,
et surtout il brille, donc on ne peut pas
voir les étoiles en arrière-plan.
Heureusement, l’astronome anglais Edmond
Halley avait au XVIIIe siècle imaginé
un moyen de contourner le problème.
En astronomie, il y a une loi fondamentale,
extrêmement importante,
qu’on appelle la troisième loi de Kepler.
Cette loi nous dit que si vous prenez
différentes planètes
en orbite autour d’une étoile, on va prendre
des orbites circulaires pour faire simple,
il existe une relation entre
la distance à l’étoile
et la période de l’orbite, c’est à dire
la durée d’une révolution.
Plus précisément cette relation nous dit
que la distance au cube est proportionnelle
à la période au carré.
La constante de proportionnalité ne dépend
que de la masse de l’étoile.
Prenons par exemple la Terre et Vénus, dans
le système solaire.
On sait que Vénus a une orbite de 220 jours,
la Terre 365 jours,
on a donc une relation entre la distance
au soleil de Vénus et celle de la Terre.
Donc si on connait la distance
du Soleil à Vénus,
on pourrait déduire celle
du Soleil à la Terre.
Bon c’est bien mais la distance du Soleil
à Vénus on ne la connait pas plus,
donc on n’est pas beaucoup plus avancé.
Mais Halley avait pensé à un moyen
de résoudre la difficulté.
Imaginez qu’on se place à un moment où
la Terre, Vénus et le Soleil sont alignés.
La distance du Soleil à Vénus, c’est la distance
Terre-Soleil moins la distance Terre-Vénus.
Si on sait mesurer la distance Terre-Vénus,
et qu’on appelle x la distance Terre-Soleil,
la loi de Kepler devient une simple équation
à une inconnue qu’on peut résoudre.
Il faut juste trouver la distance
Terre-Vénus.
Évidemment c’est une distance qui change
tout le temps,
mais on a supposé une situation où Vénus
est pile entre nous et le Soleil,
on doit donc trouver cette distance lors
d’une éclipse de Soleil par Vénus.
Alors évidemment quand Vénus passe
devant le Soleil,
ça fait pas comme une éclipse, la taille
apparente de Vénus est trop faible.
Ça fait juste une petite tache noire,
et on appelle pas ça une éclipse,
on appelle ça un "transit" de Vénus.
Ça dure quelques heures et c’est super parce
que le Soleil nous fournit l’arrière plan.
On va pouvoir utiliser la méthode
de la parallaxe.
Eh bien allons-y, prochain
transit de Vénus…
Oh non, décembre 2117!
Alors oui c’est un événement très rare.
Mais Edmond Halley qui avait imaginé
cette méthode,
savait qu’il aurait lieu en 1761
puis à nouveau en 1769.
Et cet événement a donné lieu à
ce qui peut être considéré
comme la première collaboration scientifique
internationale de l’Histoire.
A cette époque des astronomes français,
suédois, britanniques, russes, américains
se sont coordonnés pour observer et mesurer
le transit de Vénus
depuis 62 endroits différents
comme la Sibérie, Madagascar, Pondichéry,
Terre-Neuve, le cap de Bonne Espérance,
Philadelphie, Tahiti.
Tout ça, sachant que pendant ce temps-là,
les puissances européennes
étaient en plein affrontement militaire,
entre 1756 et 1763, c’était la guerre de 7 Ans.
Mais la science a été plus forte
que les conflits.
A l’aide de toutes ces mesures, l’astronome
français Jérôme de La Lande
réalisa une estimation de la distance
Terre-Soleil à 153 millions de km.
Soit une erreur de 2% par rapport
à l’estimation actuelle, vraiment pas mal!
Alors aujourd’hui on n’utilise plus
cette méthode,
même si le dernier transit de Vénus
a eu lieu en 2012
et a donné de très jolies observations.
Depuis les années 60 on mesure directement
la distance entre la Terre et Vénus
par télémétrie.
Non pas avec un laser mais avec un radar.
On mesure le temps avant de recevoir l’écho
des ondes qui se réfléchissent sur la planète,
et ça nous permet d’estimer
sa distance à la Terre,
et donc la distance Terre-Soleil.
La valeur actuellement retenue est d’environ
149,6 millions de kilomètres.
Une fois qu’on a ça, et grâce
à la loi de Kepler,
on peut en déduire les distances de toutes
les autres planètes
qui tournent autour du Soleil.
C’est bien mais pour l’instant on reste
dans le système solaire.
Maintenant essayons de voir plus loin,
on va estimer la distance qui nous sépare
des étoiles de la Voie lactée.
Pour les étoiles, on pourrait se dire
qu’on va à nouveau
utiliser la méthode de la parallaxe,
comme Hipparque avec la Lune.
Sauf qu’elles sont beaucoup plus loin
que les planètes.
Donc on va se retrouver avec des angles
ridiculement petits à mesurer.
Sauf… sauf si on utilise l’orbite
de la Terre autour du Soleil!
On a vu que ce que l’on mesure
c’est un angle,
et qu’il dépend de la base qu’on choisit
pour faire notre mesure,
c’est à dire de la distance entre
les deux points d’observations.
On a parlé de quelques centaines
de kilomètres,
ou quelques milliers si on se déplace
beaucoup sur Terre.
Mais maintenant qu’on connait la distance
Terre-Soleil, on peut utiliser ça!
Si on observe une même étoile à 6 mois
d’intervalles,
la position de la Terre aura changé
de deux fois la distance Terre-Soleil,
donc 300 millions de kilomètres.
Les angles de parallaxe seront donc
beaucoup plus facile à mesurer.
En pratique ça va quand même pas
être simple.
Prenons l’étoile la plus proche de nous,
Proxima du centaure.
Avec une base de 300 millions de kilomètres,
sa parallaxe est de 0.7 secondes d’arc.
Je vous rappelle un degré se divise
en 60 minutes et 3600 secondes,
donc là on parle même pas
d’un millième de degré.
Avec cette parallaxe de 0,7 secondes,
la distance correspondante c’est environ
4,2 années-lumière.
Retenez que la parallaxe, ça marche
à l’envers,
plus la parallaxe est faible,
plus l’objet est loin.
Et inversement, une parallaxe plus
élevée, c’est un objet plus proche.
Si sa parallaxe était de 1 seconde, l’étoile
ne serait qu’à environ 3,26 années-lumière.
D’ailleurs cette distance qui correspond
à une seconde de parallaxe,
les astronomes utilisent très souvent ça
comme unité longueur
3,26 années-lumières on appelle
ça un "parsec".
Et on va parler de kiloparsecs,
de mégaparsecs,
parsec c'est pour PARalaxe-SEConde
Pour faire simple dans cette vidéo, je vais
essayer de m’en tenir aux années-lumière,
mais si jamais je parle de parsecs,
pour avoir des années-lumière
vous multipliez en gros par 3.
Pour mesurer des parallaxes en utilisant
l’orbite de la Terre comme base,
on peut le faire depuis le sol,
avec des télescopes,
mais l’idéal, c’est quand même d’aller
dans l’espace.
En 1989, l’agence spatiale européenne
a lancé un satellite nommé Hipparcos,
en hommage à Hipparque évidemment,
et permettant de mesurer des parallaxes
avec une précision de 1 milliseconde d’arc.
Toute les données recueillies forment le
catalogue Hipparcos,
qui contient plus de 100 000 étoiles.
Pour prendre la suite d’Hipparcos,
c’est le satellite Gaïa
qui a été lancé en 2013, et dont
les résultats
sont publiés progressivement
depuis quelques années.
Le catalogue contient à l’heure actuelle
un milliard d’étoiles,
et des mesures de parallaxe avec une précision
allant jusqu'à 10 microsecondes d’arc.
Tout ça est consultable en ligne.
La méthode de la parallaxe est donc
très puissante,
et elle fonctionne car on connait
l’orbite de la Terre,
la distance Terre-Soleil, qu’on a obtenue
par télémétrie.
C’est le premier exemple de changement
de barreau de l’échelle.
La méthode de télémétrie, premier barreau,
qui fonctionne jusqu’à disons 1 milliards
de kilomètres
permet de caler la méthode de parallaxe,
le deuxième barreau, qui lui marche jusqu’à
quelques dizaines de milliers années-lumière
Grâce à cela, on peut donc estimer
l’éloignement
de près d’un milliard d’étoiles
de la Voie Lactée.
Malgré tout, ça ne représente
qu’une petite portion de notre galaxie,
notre voisinage disons.
Pour espérer mesurer la distance d’objets
plus lointains,
comme d’autres galaxies par exemple,
il nous faut une nouvelle méthode.
Pour les objets hors de notre galaxie,
on n’a aucune chance
avec une méthode purement géométrique
comme la parallaxe.
Il faudrait mesurer des angles
ridiculement petits.
Au lieu de ça, on va se servir de
ce qu’on appelle en astronomie
une « chandelle standard ».
Pour comprendre ça, on doit parler
des notions de luminosité intrinsèque,
et luminosité apparente.
Imaginez une source lumineuse familière,
disons les phares d’une voiture.
Intuitivement vous savez combien ça éclaire,
vous connaissez leur luminosité intrinsèque.
Maintenant si vous voyez les phares
d’une voiture au loin, la nuit,
leur luminosité apparente sera d’autant
plus faible que la voiture se trouve loin.
Comme vous connaissez la vraie luminosité
intrinsèque des phares,
leur luminosité apparente vous donne
une idée
de la distance à laquelle se trouve
la voiture.
Mais ça ne fonctionne que parce que
vous connaissez
la luminosité intrinsèque des phares.
Si vous voyez une source lumineuse inconnue
dans la nuit,
vous ne pouvez pas savoir a priori
s’il s’agit d’une source
puissance située très loin,
ou d’une source moins lumineuse
et située moins loin.
C’est exactement ce qui se passe avec les
étoiles d’ailleurs.
Si une étoile apparait très brillante,
c’est peut-être qu’elle est très proche,
ou bien qu’elle est très puissante.
Donc juste sa luminosité apparente,
ça ne nous dit rien sur sa distance.
Sauf si, comme pour les phares de voitures,
on connait sa vraie luminosité intrinsèque.
Un objet astrophysique dont on connait la
luminosité intrinsèque,
c’est ça qu’on appelle
une « chandelle standard ».
Et en comparant sa luminosité apparente
à sa luminosité intrinsèque,
on peut s’en servir pour estimer sa distance.
Le problème, c’est comment en trouver
des objets de ce genre?
Eh bien, la solution nous a été apportée
par l’astrophysicienne Henrietta Leavitt.
Au début du XXème siècle, Leavitt
travaille à Harvard
et étudie des étoiles qu’on appelle
des Céphéides.
Il s’agit d’étoiles dont la luminosité
oscille régulièrement avec le temps.
Leur nom, les Céphéides, vient de la première
étoile de ce genre
qui a été découverte dans la constellation
de Céphée, c’est l’étoile delta-Céphée,
vous voyez ici la variation
de sa luminosité
qui oscille avec une période
d’environ 5 jours.
On connait quelques centaines de Céphéides
dans la Voie lactée,
ce sont des étoiles assez puissantes,
qui sont environ 10 fois
plus massives que le soleil,
et dont les périodes d’oscillation vont de
quelques jours à quelques dizaines de jours.
Dans son travail de recherche,
Henrietta Leavitt
ne s’intéressait pas aux Céphéides de
la Voie lactée,
mais à celles situées dans ce qu’on appelle
le Grand Nuage de Magellan.
Le Grand Nuage de Magellan, c’est une
galaxie naine,
qui est située tout près de la Voie lactée,
et qu’on considère comme une sorte
de satellite de notre galaxie.
On peut l’observer dans la constellation
de la Dorade.
Vous ne connaissez pas cette constellation,?
C’est parce qu’elle est dans l’hémisphère Sud!
Et donc Henrietta Leavitt remarque
que les Céphéides de cette galaxie
semblent suivre une certaine régularité.
Plus leur période d’oscillation est importante,
plus elles semblent lumineuses.
Et elle trouve une formule qui permet
de relier les deux quantités.
On appelle ça la relation période-luminosité.
Comme toutes ces étoiles sont situées en
gros à la même distance de nous,
puisqu'elles sont dans le nuage de Magellan
qui est hors de la galaxie,
cette variation de luminosité apparente
semble bien être due à la luminosité
intrinsèque.
Comme si la puissance de ces étoiles dépendait
uniquement de leur période d’oscillation.
Ça c’est super car ça veut dire
que les Céphéides pourraient servir
de chandelle standard,
si on connaissait leur luminosité
intrinsèque,
en regardant leur luminosité apparente
on en déduirait par exemple la distance
du Grand Nuage de Magellan.
Le souci c’est qu’il faut calibrer
cette méthode,
on ne connait pas a priori la luminosité
intrinsèque des Céphéides.
On sait qu’elle est liée à leur période,
mais il nous faut une valeur absolue
qui serve de point de référence.
Par exemple à partir de Céphéides
dont on connaisse déjà la distance
par une autre méthode, comme celle
de la parallaxe.
Grâce au télescope spatial Hubble et au
catalogue Gaïa dont on a parlé juste avant,
il y a maintenant plusieurs dizaines
de Céphéides
dont on sait bien estimer la distance par
la méthode de la parallaxe.
On peut donc calculer leur puissance
intrinsèque
et s’en servir pour calibrer la relation
période-luminosité des Céphéides.
On a donc un nouvel exemple d’ascension
de l’échelle.
La méthode de la parallaxe,
deuxième barreau,
permet de calibrer la méthode des Céphéides,
troisième barreau.
L’avantage, c’est que si la méthode
de la parallaxe
était limitée à quelques dizaines
d’années-lumière,
les Céphéides permettent de nous
emmener beaucoup plus loin.
On peut en effet en détecter dans des
galaxies situées à des millions,
voire des dizaines de millions
d’années-lumières,
comme celle-ci, la galaxie M101.
Des dizaines de millions d’années-lumière,
c’est bien,
ça permet de connaitre la distance
de plusieurs centaines de galaxies,
nos plus proches voisines.
Mais on est encore très loin de la taille
de l’Univers visible.
Pour pousser plus loin, on ne peut pas
utiliser les Céphéides,
elles deviennent bien trop
difficile à observer.
Heureusement, il existe un autre type
de chandelle standard: les supernovas.
[Jingle]
Une supernova, c’est, en quelque sorte,
l’explosion d’une étoile en fin de vie,
et qui s’accompagne d’une émission de lumière
absolument gigantesque.
A tel point que lorsqu’elle se produit,
une supernova peut émette plus de lumière
que toute la galaxie qui l’héberge.
Ces événements sont rarissimes,
en gros dans une galaxie donnée
ça arrive moins d’une fois par siècle.
Et il y a plusieurs causes possibles.
Mais un cas particulier, c'est ce
qu’on appelle les supernovas de type 1a.
Le scénario est toujours le même: une naine
blanche en orbite autour d’une autre étoile
lui pique de la matière et grossit
jusqu’à atteindre
une limite bien définie qui la fait exploser.
Des calculs théoriques permettent d’estimer
que cette limite,
qu’on appelle la limite de Chandrasekhar,
serait d’environ 1,4 fois la masse du Soleil.
Une fois cette limite atteinte,
l’étoile implose puis explose,
sa luminosité augmente très rapidement puis
décroit en quelques dizaines de jours.
Le gros intérêt, c’est que toutes
les supernovas de type 1a explosent
plus ou moins de la même façon quand
elles atteignent la masse limite.
On a donc une belle chandelle standard,
dont la luminosité intrinsèque
est toujours la même.
Sauf que vous me voyez peut-être venir:
pour que tout ça fonctionne,
on doit calibrer la méthode.
C’est-à-dire qu’on doit déterminer cette
luminosité intrinsèque
en utilisant des supernovas assez proches
pour qu’on en connaisse déjà la distance
grâce à une autre méthode,
comme celle des Céphéides.
Heureusement c’est possible!
Par exemple la supernova de type 1a
la plus proche que l’on ait observé
est celle qu’on appelle SN1972E,
et elle s’est produite à une dizaine
de millions d’années-lumière de nous,
dans une galaxie dont on peut justement
estimer la distance
par la méthode des Céphéides.
Et on connait quelques dizaines de supernovas
du même genre,
suffisamment proches pour permettre
de calibrer la luminosité grâce aux Céphéides.
Nouveau barreau de l’échelle franchi!
Comme les supernovas sont parmi
les événements astrophysiques
les plus puissants de l’Univers,
elles vont nous permettre de mesurer
la distance de galaxies
vraiment très lointaines, jusqu’à plusieurs
milliards d’années-lumière.
Et grâce à cela, on va pouvoir grimper sur
le dernier barreau de l’échelle:
la loi de Hubble.
J’en ai déjà parlé sur la chaine
plusieurs fois,
nous savons que toutes les galaxies
s’éloignent les unes des autres
sous l’effet de l’expansion de l’Univers,
et plus elles sont lointaines, plus
elles s’éloignent vite de nous.
Plus précisément, leur vitesse d’éloignement
V, est proportionnelle à leur distance D,
et on note Ho le coefficient
de proportionnalité,
qu’on appelle la constante de Hubble, en
hommage à l’astronome Edwin Hubble
qui avait découvert cette relation.
Notons deux choses à propos
de cette découverte.
Premièrement à l’époque, elle avait été
rendue possible
justement grâce aux travaux de Henrietta
Leavitt sur les Céphéides,
qui permettaient d’estimer les distances
des galaxies les plus proches.
Deuxièmement, la valeur de la constante
de proportionnalité
trouvée par Hubble était…
assez loin du compte!
On voit ici le diagramme publié par
Hubble en 1929:
en regardant la pente de la droite, on voit
que le coefficient de proportionnalité
est environ 500 km par seconde par mégaparsec.
Une galaxie située à 1 mégaparsec semble
s’éloigner à 500 km/s.
A deux mégaparsecs c’est le double, etc.
Je rappelle: un mégaparsec, c’est environ
3 millions d’années-lumière.
Ce coefficient, on sait aujourd’hui qu’il
était surestimé presque d’un facteur 10.
La vraie valeur, c’est plutôt autour
de 70 km/s/Mpc.
Comment on le sait?
Eh bien on a fait des mesures sur beaucoup
plus de galaxies,
et surtout sur des galaxies
bien plus lointaines,
grâce aux supernovas
de la méthode précédente.
Sur le graphique que vous voyez ici,
vous avez la vitesse d’éloignement
d’un grand nombre de galaxies
ainsi que les distances associées.
La vitesse on la connait en mesurant
le décalage de fréquence de la lumière,
par un analogue de l’effet Doppler, et la
distance, on la connait grâce aux supernovas.
Donc forcément, on est beaucoup plus précis
que ne l’était Hubble
qui mesurait des galaxies vraiment
très proches.
L’estimation la plus récente de la constante
de Hubble, c’est 73 km/s/Mpc.
Et en faisant ça, on grimpe sur le dernier
barreau de notre échelle.
Les mesures de supernovas nous permettent
de calibrer la constante de Hubble,
et celle-ci nous permet d’estimer
des distances
jusqu’aux confins de l’Univers visible.
Si on a disons une galaxie très lointaine,
puisque sa distance est liée à sa vitesse
d’éloignement,
il suffit de mesurer cette vitesse.
Or grâce au phénomène de décalage
vers le rouge,
en observant les longueurs d’onde émises
on peut en déduire la vitesse d’éloignement,
même pour des objets très lointains.
C’est ainsi qu’on a pu mesurer la distance
de la galaxie
la plus lointaine connue à ce jour,
qu’on appelle GN-z11.
Et là vous allez voir c’est un peu subtil.
La lumière qu’on observe de cette galaxie
a été émise il y a 13,4 milliards d’années,
soit 400 millions d’années seulement
après le big-bang.
Cette lumière que l’on capte aujourd’hui
a donc voyagé 13,4 milliards
d’années-lumière avant de nous arriver.
On pourrait se dire que la galaxie
est à 13,4 milliards d’années-lumière.
Mais du fait de l’expansion de l’Univers,
on sait que cette galaxie est aujourd’hui
bien plus loin, à une distance d’environ
32 milliards d’années-lumière.
Pour résumer, vous voyez que grâce
aux différentes méthodes dont on a parlé,
et à leur recouvrement qui permet de les
calibrer successivement,
il est possible de mesurer des distances
jusqu’aux confins de l’Univers visible,
et ce avec finalement assez peu d’hypothèses.
Et pourtant il y a en ce moment en cosmologie
une crise qui se dessine
et qui découle de la mesure
de la constante de Hubble.
Je vous l’ai dit, on a trouvé
environ 73 km/s/Mpc.
Or une autre méthode, basée cette fois sur
le rayonnement fossile donne plutôt 67.
Pour les mesures de distance, ça ne fait pas
une grande différence de précision, environ 10%.
Mais au fur et à mesure que les barres
d’erreur se réduisent,
les cosmologistes commencent à réaliser
que ces deux mesures
pourraient bien être vraiment incompatibles.
Indiquant que l’une des deux doit être
un peu fausse.
Mais laquelle?
Cette tension sur la mesure de la constante
de Hubble est aujourd’hui
un sujet chaud en cosmologie, mais je vous
en parlerai dans un prochain épisode!
Merci d’avoir suivi la vidéo.
N’oubliez pas de partager pour m’aider
à faire connaitre la chaine.
Abonnez vous si ça n’est pas déjà fait,
la cloche, tout ça.
Pour les plus curieux je donne comme toujours
des compléments dans le billet de blog,
le lien est en description,
et nous, on se retrouve très vite pour
une nouvelle vidéo, à bientôt!
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -